mental health man you know knowing what
can happen and how it happens and how
how you're not going to be aware that
it's happening and these are the warning
signs and don't [ __ ] around because
you're going to wake up one day people
don't think it'll it'll be them and it
is number one killer cops is suicide
really number one killer cops is suicide
they didn't have a gun
yes so you're halfway there if you want
to gosh guy we had a guy that was in the
police department right next to us
um ended up getting into his car and
with his the duty shotgun blew his head
off right before he went out for the
shift was supposed to start but the
number one killer is cops they never
tell you that they never talk about
mental health I went through the entire
Academy they taught me how to
put on a tourniquet heal a sucking chest
wound they taught me so many things but
they never made one mention of how to
you know how to work with your own head
wow you know they never said suicide's
number one killer cops I think that's
changed I know it's changed but it's
getting a lot better
um but at that point there was no
mention of that and these things
accumulate I'm giving you
one portion of one day oh I can't
imagine especially like you know like I
grew up with a lot of childhood trauma
and um a lot of people have right and
it's really common and
um and that is tough enough to deal with
in regular life as it comes up later and
you realize there's ways that it affects
you as an adult right yes I can't
imagine
[Music]
um
whatever traumas you already have are
things that could have happened in your
past and then you're now just engulfed
in this you're like a do you feel like a
damn for trauma for people like do you
feel like a reciprocal for me yeah
because there's so many things and then
you just have to go on to the next call
is there
um it depends you know people don't take
it it's just there's no way to really
understand
all the things that you experience just
in the shift right let alone over a
20-year career especially if you're
working different assignments these
horrific things so the only people you
do talk about that with are these guys
that you're doing it with and nine times
out of ten when you do talk about it
later it's just it feels so
inappropriate because you're it becomes
a joke right the most horrific
situations
they become funny you know and it and
anyone else that hears that it's it is a
hard pill to swallow you know it's a
hard for the general public to go why
the [ __ ] are they laughing right you
know what's so funny you'll see
sometimes on TV I'll see like homicide
scenes on TV and I'll and I'll I'll look
at because I'm conscious I'm aware of
this I'll look at the officers around
and you do it for now on you'll see
every once in a while you'll see two
guys and they'll be horrific murder
scene shootings whatever and there's be
two [ __ ] cops right there and they'll
be laughing wow you know they'll be
communicating together to be laughing
and you go like oh dude that's such bad
Optics that's such but you totally
understand it right you know the rest of
the world doesn't you're going through
such insane situations you know and it's
so interesting that you guys use humor
to cope because it's the same thing it's
the same thing why a lot of comedians
get into things you know things were
traumatic or some type of way and so
they used humor to survive you know I
think it's amazing that mother nature
uses that as like a uh like a governor
on us you know yeah where it's like if
you get so so far you just laugh I think
it's why the Joker laughs in the Joker
movies because at a certain point he's
just so mad yeah that oh there's nothing
left to do but laugh at it you know
pretty much the situations are so
outrageous and like you said as far as
the bonds
please please there is strong bonds and
and I'm married love my wife we've been
together for 20 years we talk about
everything my best friend my entire
career I never went home and I never
discussed anything with her
literally never discussed anything there
was never a good time to come home and
say Hey you know I saw a [ __ ] kid die
today you know all the things that went
on during the day unless it was like
really light and really I never told her
anything traumatic wow because she's
it's just never a good time one of my
close friends in the police department I
became a patrol sergeant and it was a
female most squared away female cop
you've ever seen just looked at her and
she screamed cop great cop good person
totally solid as time went on she
started to deteriorate mentally and
because my generation never been taught
about it we would you know you just need
to sack yeah suck the [ __ ] up you know
toughen up Tom that's it you need a cup
of sock to [ __ ] up and let's get back to
business yeah so we [ __ ] hardened
that vulva buddy that's it you know and
we would not we just didn't know whether
it was well long story short she ended
up not showing up for work and she ended
up killing herself she ended up hanging
herself and I actually went to the house
and found her
um and with hindsight looking back at
there was so many warning signs there
were so many things that she did when
she was begging for help she actually
came into the police department at one
point and was hysterical and acting
crazy and I had a pretty good
relationship with her so I told my
lieutenant I'll go out and talk to her I
want to talk to her and I remember
walking in and going holy [ __ ] she's
gonna kill herself she's so bad we're
like even thinking that but it was
almost like this passive weird thing
that we just think I said it I said it
out loud she's gonna kill herself she's
that crazy things are that bad right now
is what I was thinking and doing what
cops did we made a [ __ ] joke out of
her I remember laughing I remember
laughing and a week later she was dead
not everybody sees this stuff you know
nobody not everybody sees
some blow their head off you know what I
mean try that once see how that changes
your life I can't even imagine it really
take one person and watch one time watch
someone in front of them blow their head
off and then and then see how it changed
do an experiment follow that guy around
see how that changes like now take that
guy that same guy and do it for 20 years
every single day
you know what do you expect I got a guy
that I worked with who's in Texas right
now he's he's working in a program a
religious program that reaches out and
helps cops and firemen and First
Responders with mental wellness and
that's what they call Dina uh Charter
Oaks Charter Oaks Academy or no not
Charter Oaks Charter Oak something but
he um he just made me aware that this
one police department in the last couple
months six hot cops killed themselves
you know you just don't hear about that
because it's bad publicity cops don't
even want that out you know it's a scary
thing when someone says oh cops are all
killing themselves wow all the cops are
unstable there just is no good publicity
for cops you know so and what's happened
recently
what happened this last time
with the uh the riots and the the
political aspect that got involved and
allowed it to continue in the way it was
put on the media and portrayed
it's it's it set us back a lot it set
policing back a lot
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one